[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
l'émission sur TV 78 pour bien démarrer
la soirée j'espère que le week-end a été
bon comme d'habitude on fait le plein et
d'actualité d'infopratiques et d'idées
de sortie voici le programme de ce mardi
30 mai
un chef Papou devant les élèves du lycée
de Villaroy Guyancourt la rencontre
s'est déroulée ce matin mundiya kepanga
est venu à présenter un film sur la
déforestation en Papouasie Nouvelle
Guinée le détail dont les informations
du jour nous reviendrons également sur
un premier feu de forêt qui s'est
déclaré dimanche dans le sud des
Yvelines et des nageurs dont la pièce
d'eau des Suisses si vous êtes baladé du
côté du château de Versailles dimanche
vous les avez peut-être remarqué le
Versailles triathlon festival prenait
place dans la cité royale l'épreuve
reine du week-end le triathlon du roi ou
500 courageux ont enchaîné natation vélo
et course à pied et puis les fans de la
pop culture avaient rendez-vous au
Clayes-sous-Bois le geek-up festival se
déroulait samedi et dimanche dernier au
parc de Diane des Clayes-sous-Bois
cosplay animation et rencontre au
programme cette année deux acteurs de la
saga Harry Potter était de la partie
retour dans le 7 8
et des invités également autour de cette
table on parle dans le 7 8 et des
journées nationales de la Croix-Rouge
elle se tiennent du 3 au 11 juin c'est
partout en France et aussi dans les
Yvelines et Martine Delabarre est avec
nous bonsoir présidente de la délégation
territoriale des Yvelines donc de la
Croix-Rouge l'objectif des journées
c'est de collecter des dons essentiels
pour la poursuite de vos actions de
solidarité comment se porte la
Croix-Rouge on avait reçu récemment des
bénévoles de l'épicerie solidaire sur
sur l'antenne de d'Élancourt trap qui
faisait face à des difficultés d'accord
je vous remercie de nous accueillir une
année supplémentaire tous les ans pour
l'ouverture donc des Journées nationales
à partir du 3 du 3 au 11 juin
alors oui vous avez reçu parce
qu'effectivement comme plein
d'associations on cherche un peu des
bénévoles c'est vrai parce que le
bénévolat changé parce que nous on doit
s'adapter ce qu'on est en train de faire
donc n'hésitez pas si vous nous écoutez
rejoindre les unités local partout
autour de vous dans les Yvelines on
pourra vous proposer des choses adaptées
à ce que vous souhaitez faire parce que
c'est vrai que le bénévolat a changé je
sais pas je me tourne aussi vers vous
voilà mais bon à part ça évidemment on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'activités vous avez
posé la question est-ce qu'on a besoin
si vous voulez on comme les autres
préfèrent
avoir moins à faire pour tout vous dire
vraiment
le tout toutes les crises que nous avons
vécu et l'Ukraine et l'inflation c'est
compliqué pour la Croix-Rouge comme pour
les autres associations donc c'est vrai
que les dons sont vraiment cette année
les bienvenus mais réellement c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est important on
a 22% de personnes en plus dans nos dans
nos alimentations dans nos aides
alimentaires épicerie sociale il y a
vraiment un besoin aujourd'hui énorme on
trouve moins de denrées il faut les
acheter tout ce qui est hygiène pour
bébé ça y est je suis lancée
juste pour faire un petit teasing
d'ailleurs vous êtes venus avec la
traditionnelle exactement
de la Croix-Rouge française
journée nationale dans ce 7 8 il y aura
aussi une large page dédiée à la culture
avec deux événements le premier TV 78 en
est partenaire c'est tracteur blues qui
revient les deux et trois juin le
festival s'arrêtent dans deux villages à
Breuil boire Aubert et Medan et on en
parle avec Chantal si peletti bonsoir
bonsoir présidente de blues sur scène
car derrière l'organisation c'est la
même équipe que le festival bus sur
scène qu'on a l'habitude de retrouver en
fin d'année dans les Yvelines le
principe de tracteur blues est-ce que
c'est la déclinaison estivale de Blue
sur scène ce qu'on peut le présenter
comme ça on peut vous présenter comme ça
l'idée première c'est d'amener la le
spectacle vivant au cœur des villages ce
sont des villages de moins de 2000
habitants qui n'ont pas de salle de
spectacle et bien nous nous arrivons
avec la scène tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire une belle journée de festival qui
est résonnera une nouvelle fois cette
fois-ci en extérieur dans ces deux
villages on pourrait voir Robert et mes
dents et on en parlera tout à l'heure
également dans cette édition de la
musique vous l'avez compris mais aussi
de la littérature cet événement pourrait
vous intéresser si vous êtes passionné
de livre le salon à écrire à Versailles
revient avec une cinquième édition qui
se déroule samedi prochain au quartier
des antiquaires on en parle avec Olivier
certain ce qui fait partie bonsoir de
l'équipe d'organisation vous êtes le
trésorier du salon écrire à Versailles
qui est dédié vraiment aux auteurs du
territoire de Versailles rempart qu'on
pourra faire leur rencontre exactement
en fait
nous avons créé il y a cinq ans
cette rencontre et puis ben voilà ce
sont des gens qui viennent
de Versailles mettre de la région et
puis et ça permet de les rencontrer et
il y a des signatures etc et c'est très
sympa sur cette cinquième édition aussi
dans la partie culture tout à l'heure et
à vos côtés Gabriel Gontier bonsoir de
la rédaction de tv78 avec vous à suivre
les informations du jour vous nous ferez
aussi un point sur les résultats sport à
retenir de ce weekend de la Pentecôte
dans les Yvelines on va revenir
également sur la 30e édition du Trophée
Sport Passion qui se déroulait la
semaine dernière à Feucherolles et puis
comme chaque mardi les insolites de
Véronique qui turbitent ces informations
originales qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans le 7 8 voilà le programme
mais avant tout cela on va jeter un coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
l'été en avant-première dans les
Yvelines avec une semaine ensoleillée
qui s'annonce demain matin c'est bien le
cas avec une température de 15 degrés
sur l'ensemble du territoire et dans
l'après midi les conditions n'évoluent
pas le thermomètre grimpe il va faire
chaud avec 24 degrés à Rambouillet à
Versailles et Houdan et même 25 degrés à
Versailles le vent sera également
présent ça peut souffler jusqu'à 40 km/h
côté éphéméride demain c'est la saint
Ferdinand on fait le point à présent sur
les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines
température estivale du week-end ça
s'est déjà passé ce week-end avec
Gabriel et malheureusement ça lance
aussi une autre saison plus malheureuse
celle des incendies en forêt des feux de
forêt Grégory et c'est le sud des
Yvelines qui a été touché ce weekend à
Sonchamp le feu a été rapidement
maîtrisé par les pompiers heureusement
mobilisés qui étaient assistés d'un
drone deux hectares de forêts sont
partis en furet en fumée pardon tout de
même l'année dernière les premiers feux
de forêt c'était déclarés dès avril dans
le département ce premier feu laisse
présager un été sous tension pour les
sapeurs-pompiers conscients de
l'importance des risques liés au
changement climatiques le jeudi 78 suit
une formation continue aujourd'hui c'est
10% des effectifs qui sont spécialisés
dans les feux de forêt dans les Yvelines
mais cette année tous les officiers
yvinois ils sont sensibilisés direction
Guyancourt je le disais dans les titres
les lycéens ce matin ont pu faire une
rencontre insolite insolite parce qu'on
ne rencontre pas un chef papoudant les
Yvelines tous les jours et pourtant ce
matin les élèves du lycée de Villaroy
ont eu la chance d'accueillir mundiya
kepanga dans leur établissement le but
de sa visite sensibiliser au
développement durable notamment avec la
projection d'un film intuitif intitulé
frère des arbres sur la déforestation en
Papouasie une Nouvelle Guinée cette
projection était suivie d'un temps
d'échange avec les lycéens défenseurs de
l'environnement à l'international cette
rencontre avec pour but de montrer aux
élèves l'importance de chacun dans cette
cause on l'écoute au micro de Nicolas
dandry
je pense que chacun a un rôle à jouer le
moins je dois défendre la forêt de
Papouasie mais je pense que les élèves
qui sont ici ont un rôle essentiel à
jouer aussi ici chez eux en France
d'abord dans leur jardin dans leur
commune dans leur communauté dans leur
province leur région je crois que chacun
doit agir de façon locale pour avoir une
action mondiale globale en protégeant
votre nature ici et bien c'est un impact
sur le monde entier et moi en protégeant
mes arbres ça aussi un impact sur le
monde entier donc je pense que chacun a
un rôle à jouer mais vraiment très
localement
il ne reviendront plus longuement sur
cette visite demain dans le 7 8 on
continue on continue de parler
d'éducation une information à ne pas
louper si vous êtes boursier ou si vous
souhaitez le devenir oui à vie aux
étudiants et aux futurs étudiants vous
avez jusqu'à demain mercredi au 31 mai
pour faire vos demandes de bourse et de
logement étudiants pour la rentrée 2023
car attention l'attribution n'est pas
automatique vous devez vous connecter
sur la plateforme mes services
étudiants.gouv.fr pour constituer votre
dossier à noter Grégory que cette année
les bourses CROUS seront revalorisées de
37 euros pour tous les échelons ce
chiffre du jour à présent qui concerne
le week-end de pèlerinage à Chartres qui
est passé dans les Yvelines et oui en ce
week-end de Pentecôte la ville a battu
un record rassemblant près de 16000
pèlerins qui ont marché de Paris à
Chartres vous l'avez dit pour allier les
97 km de trajet alors ils sont passés
dans les Yvelines notamment à
Rambouillet et dans la vallée de
Chevreuse pour sa 41ème édition le
pèlerinage a connu une participation
record de plus de 53% par rapport à
l'année dernière
[Musique]
du 3 au 11 juin les bénévoles de la
Croix-Rouge française seront tirelire à
la main sur le terrain pour aller à
votre rencontre à l'occasion des
Journées Nationales de l'association
Martine Delabarre vous êtes avec nous
pour parler de cet événement présidente
de la délégation Évelyne de la
Croix-Rouge alors vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure la situation un peu
particulière traversée par l'association
c'est le cas aussi pour d'autres
associations sur le point de vue des
bénévoles donc ces journées on le
rappelle elles ont pour but de collecter
des dons elles sont l'imagine
primordiale pour poursuivre vos actions
vos actions auprès des publics elles
sont primordiales enfin c'est dont sont
primordiaux parce que on a besoin
localement de d'argent pour faire nos
actions comme tout simplement et
effectivement avec les crises les
épidémies qu'on a eu suivi des crises et
de l'inflation c'est compliqué pour les
personnes de se nourrir ils ont des
besoins qui ont beaucoup augmenté et
nous en fait on nous demande beaucoup
beaucoup donc il faut donner à la
Croix-Rouge puisque c'est retournée
nationale de la Croix-Rouge bien sûr
entre le 3 et le 11 novembre
dans les 11 épiceries sociales que nous
avons ainsi que le camion mobile que
nous avions Croix-Rouge sur vous que
nous avons également donc c'est vrai que
ces journées nationales c'est aussi une
journée de reconnaissance pour les 2000
bénévoles que nous sommes dans les
Yvelines et pour les 600 salariés qu'il
y a également dans les dans les Yvelines
c'est une journée de cohésion enfin une
semaine de cohésion très importante et
qui va nous permettre de faire des
actions donc alimentaires ça je vous en
ai parlé
que on connaît l'action alimentaire en
premier lieu mais d'autres actions sont
assurées pour la Croix-Rouge nous gérons
l'urgence nous devons répondre nous
sommes auxiliaires de l'État donc nous
répondons lorsque nous l'état nous
déclenche pour tout pour tout un
incendie des tout ce que vous voulez et
là nous avons des coûts quand on montre
un centre d'accueil il nous faut des
lits qu'on doit changer souvent des
lipiks qu'on monte un jour vous viendrez
apprendre comment on fait non non mais
c'est voilà on a beaucoup de matériel à
acheter quand on fait des formations au
grand public même si elles sont payantes
quand on doit renouveler le matériel de
formation au premier secours grand
public on a besoin d'argent donc en fait
on a besoin d'argent pour énormément de
choses en fait
je pense aussi aux maraude
parce qu'on parle des effectivement des
personnes en face des bénéficiaires qui
qui ont besoin de votre aide mais se
procurer des denrées alimentaires coûte
plus cher aussi pour l'association à la
fois l'essence pour les maraudes et on
est nous Samu Social donc on fait
beaucoup de maraudes partout dans les
Yvelines les Yvelines c'est un grand
grand territoire donc quand on part du
Nord enfin on essaie de répartir pour
pas le DF enfin le tout ce qui est
électricité c'est vrai que tout ça ça a
augmenté on le prend de plein fouet donc
effectivement on a vraiment
beaucoup de dépenses qui ont augmenté
donc n'hésitez pas vraiment donner même
un euro je veux dire vraiment
l'équivalent d'un repas c'est ça avec un
euro on peut déjà aider l'association
non mais effectivement il faut donner il
y a plusieurs manières alors je sais pas
si vous allez me le demander de donner
alors nous on a relié celle par SMS
notamment on peut faire un don de 5
euros en envoyant dont 78 ou 92200 il y
a aussi tout ce qui est produit
d'hygiène pour les mamans et les enfants
je vous le dis parce qu'on a une
augmentation énorme de familles avec
maman et enfants en bas âge qui viennent
nous voir on a des espaces bébé parents
et vraiment on a de gros gros besoins
voilà je vous envoie bénévole d'un jour
pour séjourner ou peut-être bénévoles
toujours sur pour la Croix Rouge c'est
là où nous on va s'adapter vous voyez
effectivement rejoignez-nous venez que
tu es une heure et demie ça nous fera
une heure et demie un tronc qui va se
remplir vraiment voilà vous pouvez venir
nous rejoindre vous avez 16 unités
locales réparties dans les Yvelines
aller sur le site WW Croix Rouge
Française vous trouverez toutes les
adresses des unités locales absolument
c'est de plus en plus difficile
aujourd'hui de trouver des bénévoles
vous le disiez alors nous on avait reçu
très dernièrement les responsables de
l'antenne de l'épicerie sociale
d'élancourts et justement à cause du
manque de bénévoles il y a un risque
pour l'avenir de cette structure alors
ça c'est vraiment très important
d'essayer de venir la Croix-Rouge peut
proposer plein d'actions différentes
alors il y a l'alimentaire c'est vrai
mais vous pouvez venir aussi pour
l'urgence vous pouvez venir aussi pour
en fait on peut trouver son bonheur dans
plein d'actions différentes à la
Croix-Rouge on peut devenir secouriste
on a besoin de secourisme on peut voilà
donc l'alimentaire oui on a besoin de
bénévoles et puis nous on va essayer de
faire évoluer nos horaires de pouvoir on
a plein de choses à faire nous également
pour que les gens viennent et ils vont
finir par revenir on en a encore
heureusement
on traverse une crise du bénévolat vous
le ressentez aussi au niveau de
l'organisation de festival comme blue
sur scène a beaucoup de chance nous
avons un groupe de bénévoles fidèles
depuis très longtemps et ils sont
toujours là ils sont nous avons pour les
deux festivals plus de 70 bénévoles
un dernier mot Martine Delabarre sur
quel appel vous souhaitez passer au
téléspectateurs à l'orée de ses journées
vraiment vous allez trouver des
bénévoles sur tous les croisements des
gros Carrefour dans les marchés dans les
supermarchés
faites-leur le meilleur accueil voilà si
si vous je crois que nous on nous voit
souvent dans les routes on nous voit
souvent d'urgence
vraiment c'est le moment de nous dire on
vous soutient en fait soutenez-nous
voilà et donc pour vous soutenir il
faudrait être présent pour ces journées
du 3 en juin et le 11 juin c'est aussi
toute l'année mais bien sûr cette date
c'est ces dates ce sont bien sûr celles
des journées nationales de la
Croix-Rouge avec toutes les informations
à retrouver bien sûr sur le site
internet de la Croix-Rouge qui s'affiche
sur l'écran merci Martine Delabarre
présente de la délégation des Yvelines
de la Croix-Rouge une immersion à
présent dans l'univers judiciaire pour
les élèves du collège Charles Péguy
c'est enchaîné Rocancourt après avoir
rencontré des personnalités politiques
les jeux n'ont plus échanger jeudi 25
mai avec Marc Trévidic cet ancien juge
anti-terroriste et célèbre pour avoir
traité les attentats de Paris dans les
années 80 et 90 au cours de cette
entretien les congés les collégiens ont
pu comprendre l'utilité de la fonction
de magistrat et parler des différentes
affaires traitées par Marc Trevidic les
propos recueillis par Julien Leroy
c'était essentiel de parler aux enfants
de la justice en fait c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important dans une
démocratie et finalement on aborde
souvent uniquement par les faits divers
par les histoires politiques ou
financières et pas en tant
qu'institution comment on pourrait faire
pour que ça fonctionne bien et que que
la fille c'est un rôle vraiment de
paix social finalement
oui ça fait une bonne entrée en matière
le fait qu'on peut juger des personnes
qui s'évadent et qui vont dans d'autres
endroits du monde et qu'on peut quand
même les juger par la suite oui enfin
qui se fasse punir pour leurs actes oui
j'ai trouvé ça sécurisant
c'est l'heure d'ouvrir la page sport
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
assez inhabituel mais aux commandes
aujourd'hui c'est Gabriel Gontier pour
vous donner les résultats sports du
week-end vous êtes vraiment sur tous les
terrains on peut le dire ce soir à
Gabriel on va commencer avec Roland
Garros ça a débuté ce week-end du côté
de la Porte d'Auteuil à Paris oui
sur les cours d'abord dans le tableau
féminin la saint germanoise Caroline
Garcia numéro 5 mondial au classement
WTA au premier tour à la remporté son
match contre la chinoise shiwang en 3.7
une rencontre accrochée le score
7,64664 au second tour elle sera opposée
à la russe Ana blinkova 56e mondial qui
est sur les cours en ce moment même
c'est Arthur rinderknech Saint-Germain
qui est opposé à Richard Gasquet pour le
premier tour de Roland-Garros la
rencontre se déroule sur le cours
Suzanne Lenglen dans le premier set
Arthur underkness actuellement 5 jeux à
4 40 partout dans le jeu actuellement il
vient de prendre un avantage alors sur
undernech on vous donnera bien sûr
toutes les informations d'ici la fin de
cette émission le résultat également en
football Versailles qui jouait sa
dernière journée dans le championnat
national oui les joueurs de la cité
royale terminent leur saison sur une
défaite malheureusement une 5c ligne 4
bus 3 face à Martigues lors de la 34e et
dernière journée pour leur première
saison en National Versailles terminale
à la 5e place au classement pour rappel
à la mi-saison les Versailles étaient
leader du championnat qui était entraîné
par le Brésilien Chris qu'on a connu
comme joueur professionnel du côté de
l'Olympique Lyonnais cris qui annoncé ce
soir sur ses réseaux sociaux c'est tout
frais ça a été annoncé dans l'après-midi
qu'il mettait fin à son contrat à son
aventure Versailles le contrat devait
quoi qu'il arrive prendre fin
aujourd'hui la confirmer Chris sur ses
réseaux sociaux que le contrat n'irait
pas au-delà de la date indiquée il avait
repris on le rappelle les reines du club
après les après que le club se soit
séparé pardon de l'autre coach
Youssef chibi en cours de saison qui a
été visé par des affaires judiciaires
première saison en Nationale donc verset
qui termine la 5e place vous le disiez
on passe
à l'échelon inférieur c'est le
championnat national de Jean-Pierre mémo
oui en proie des difficultés
administratives et sous la menace d'une
relégation au niveau régionale Poissy
c'est incliné à domicile de A1 contre
Beauvais lors de la 29e journée les
picia cacheront de leur dernier match de
la saison arène face au Stade Rennais 2
ce samedi 3 juin au classement Poissy
pointe à la 6e place avec 41 points à
deux points de Saint-Malo 5e on passe au
rugby mauvaise nouvelle pour nos clubs
yvelin
Grégory d'abord la Fédérale 3 en 8e de
finale le MLS GP s'est incliné face au
périgourdin de Sarlat 25 à 11 le club de
Maisons-Laffitte Saint-Germain-en-Laye
Poissy et donc éliminer des phases
finales mais vous le savez le MLSGP
évoluera en Fédérale 2 la saison
prochaine
fin de saison donc également vous le
disiez pour pour Chevreux et on va
terminer c'est résultat sport par de
l'aviron Gabriel direction la Slovénie
Grégory à Blade livelinoise claire
Beauvais et sabinome Laura tarentola ont
remporté une médaille de bronze en cas
en catégorie 2 de couple poils léger
c'était samedi dernier lors des
championnats d'Europe d'aviron pour
rappel claire Beauvais est originaire
d'Aubergenville actuellement licencié à
l'Association Sportive nantaise elle
tentera de faire mieux que sa médaille
d'argent au jeu de Tokyo l'année
prochaine lors des Jeux olympiques de
Paris merci Gabriel pour ces
informations sportives de la natation du
vélo et en fin de la course à pied
samedi à 27 et dimanche 28 mai avait
lieu à Versailles le Versailles
triathlon festival dans la célèbre cité
royale l'événement a réuni 1400
participants durant le week-end on
revient sur cet événement avec Mathilde
Franco et Mélanie poquet 9h du matin top
des premières étapes de ce Versailles
triathlon festival la natation dans la
fameuse pièce d'eau des Suisses les
athlètes devaient parcourir une boucle
de 750 mètres dans ce cadre unique en
face du château de Versailles
et l'excitation était palpable chez les
500 participants du triathlon du roi
épreuve phare du Versailles triathlon
festival son premier triathlon donc ce
sera le premier test grandeur nature la
première fois que je suis sur un
événement
organisé comme ça même peut-être la
première fois que je vais enchaîner les
trois sports donc j'y vais en total
découverte je vais pas pour pour aller
chercher un résultat chronométrique mais
juste pour me faire plaisir voilà le
parcours le cadre le plan de des Suisses
est à côté du château de Versailles
c'est pas loin de chez moi donc ouais
c'est un triathlon qui me plaît pour moi
c'est très important aujourd'hui c'est
mon premier traitement de la vie ça fait
un an que je m'entraîne pour moi c'est
un peu un challenge de me dire est-ce
que je peux faire trois disciplines
enchaînés c'est pas un format très large
pour moi c'est parfait pour débuter
après la natation les participants ont
dû rapidement enfiler leur tenue de
cyclistes pour s'élancer sur un parcours
de 20 km cette année le dénivelé était
plus qu'exigeant et a mis un rude
épreuve les sportifs
[Applaudissements]
enfin la dernière épreuve la course à
pied les athlètes ont dû effectuer deux
tours autour de la pièce d'eau des
Suisses c'est un week-end de fête du
sport enchaîné avec des épreuves pour
tous les âges plusieurs disciplines tous
les niveaux de pratique du complet
débutant jusqu'à l'élite le maître mot
c'est de pouvoir accueillir tout le
monde et le grand vainqueur du triathlon
du roi Axel Hamon et s'entraîne avec le
club Poissy triathlon et la terminer en
une heure une minute et 28 secondes
j'avais fait l'année dernière en
finissant 16ème avec un beau plateau là
j'avais vu qu'il y avait pas mal de
monde aussi donc j'étais venu un peu en
course de préparation pour les
championnats de France la semaine
prochaine et de venir gagner là c'est
c'est plutôt cool la course s'est jouée
dans le sprint de final le deuxième est
arrivé avec 10 secondes de retard mais
toujours avec le sourire
juste avant de passer à la suite on
revient sur les résultats sport avec
vous Gabriel Gontier vous nous parliez
effectivement de la fin de saison pour
le MLS GP également fin de saison pour
Chevreuse en rugby en huitième de finale
de Régionale 1 sainte est venue à bout
des chevrotins une courte défaite d'un
point 27 à 26 comme le MLS GP Chevreuse
accède à la division supérieure les
joueurs de la vallée de l'Yvette
évolueront en Fédérale 3 et puis on
reparle de tennis Arthur undercles a
gagné le premier set face à Richard
Gasquet dans ce premier tour de
Roland-Garros qui se déroule bien sûr en
ce moment du côté de la Porte d'Auteuil
on fera un dernier point sur le résultat
de livelinois en face à Richard Gasquet
à la fin de cette édition 30 ans pour le
Trophée Sport Passion l'événement de
golf créé par Régine Gandolfini se
déroulait jeudi dernier à Feucherolles
les sportifs de haut niveau anciences et
actuel ont pu une nouvelle fois fait on
fait une nouvelle fois le déplacement et
notamment le parrain de cette 30e
édition l'entraîneur Antoine Kombouaré
retour sur l'événement avec les images
de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude c'est sous
un soleil magnifique que s'est déroulé
ce jeudi 25 mai le trophée Sport Passion
au yogolf de Feucherolles comme
d'habitude les sportifs de haut niveau
avaient rendez-vous pour des parties de
golf mais cet événement qui fête cette
année son 30e anniversaire aussi une
vocation solidaire autour sur la 30e
édition
[Musique]
et derrière le trophée Sport Passion
Régine Gandolfini bien sûr bonjour
Régine bonjour on pouvait pas rêver
mieux pour la 30e édition du Trophée
Sport Passion au niveau du temps ou au
niveau des participants au niveau des
participants mais là je me référer
effectivement autant qui est magnifique
aujourd'hui à Feucherolles il fait très
très bon on est content bon un petit peu
froid mais la température va monter ça
va être très bien et de toute façon pour
jouer il vaut mieux ne pas avoir trop
chaud donc ça va très bien elle est
particulière je le disais 30e
anniversaire cette année du Trophée
Sport Passion ça représente quoi pour
vous de passer ce cap des 30 ans
rien
c'est voilà c'est assez étonnant et j'ai
l'impression que ça ça perturbe plus les
gens qui étaient là il y a 30 ans où il
y a 29 ans et qui me disent tu te rends
compte ça fait 30 ans pour moi ça a été
une année après une année après une
année je dirais que pendant les
10 15 premières années c'était à chaque
fois de me dire est-ce que je réussirai
à le faire l'année prochaine tellement
c'était compliqué sur un plan économique
en fait d'organiser un trophée comme
celui-là et depuis que je suis
accompagnée par le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines et par notre partenaire
testo qui était là depuis très très
longtemps ça a été plus de se dire
maintenant
on est on est dans la dans la dans la
poursuite dans la durée de l'événement
et avec des habitués vous le dites il y
a aussi des nouveaux venus qu'est-ce qui
fait la réussite vous l'avez dit c'est
de se retrouver sur une journée il y a
un public fidèle mais aussi de nouveaux
venus qui qui viennent aussi sur sur ce
trophée Sport Passion on en a oui alors
on a je dirais que les fidèles quand ils
peuvent se libérer ils sont ils le
notent ils sont là donc ça c'est très
important tout à l'heure je parle avec
Philippe Candeloro et il me disait tu te
rends compte on a vieilli quand même été
dit on a vieilli mais c'est incroyable
quand même 30 ans et il me dit comment
tu as fait il m'a posé la question
Philippe et je lui ai dit mais j'ai
réussi à grâce à toi toi et d'autres
parce que quand vous vous venez pour moi
vous êtes comme des Ethem c'est sur les
bateaux c'est voilà je suis étayée par
eux en fait par ces sportifs qui sont
très connus qui m'aident après les
nouveaux c'est peut-être parce qu'ils se
disent euh bah le golf je connais je
joue et j'ai envie de participer une
journée de golf ou je connais pas et
j'ai envie de découvrir donc ça c'est
important et c'est aussi de se dire bah
j'ai envie de voir les autres et
forcément le fil rouge de la journée
c'est le golf mais il y a aussi des
animations là aujourd'hui quel est le
programme des animations du jour alors
on a donc on soutient depuis maintenant
4-5 ans une fédération sportive qui
s'appelle eufolep donc fédération
multisport qui permet qui beaucoup pour
l'insertion des jeunes vers le sport
ils font beaucoup beaucoup de travail
social pour pouvoir amener les gens à
faire du sport ça peut être des adultes
également et donc nous on les soutient
grâce aux conseils départemental on leur
donne un chèque de 4000 € chaque année
donc ils nous ont mis un mur d'escalade
on a du panafoot qui va être là on a du
drone soccer et nous mettre de leidens
enfin il y a plein plein d'animations
toute l'après-midi qui vont être mises
en place là qui commence et qui vont
durer jusqu'à ce soir alors vous l'avez
dit elle sera ma dernière question 30
ans finalement c'est qu'un chiffre pour
vous on lui souhaite quoi au Trophée
Sport Passion 30 ans supplémentaires
pourquoi pas avec avec une transmission
bien sûr parce que moi dans 30 ans je
sais pas mais non j'ai envie de dire pas
30 ans supplémentaires de à l'année
prochaine merci Régine Gandolfini très
bon anniversaire pour ses 30 ans du
Trophée Sport Passion on va aller à
présent à la rencontre des sportifs qui
étaient présents sur cette journée
et comme le disait Régine Gandolfini à
côté des parties de Golfe également des
animations qui sont assurés en plus par
les sportifs qui sont présents notamment
par Cyril carré bonjour bonjour alors
cet après-midi vous allez faire vous une
initiation enfin vous avez ramené votre
kayak et vous allez pouvoir faire
découvrir le kayak aux personnes
présentes oui ça c'est ça ça s'est prévu
au dernier moment j'ai proposé d'amener
mon kayak de course donc ça va être une
animation sympa à regarder c'est un
bateau très instable donc on va voir les
plus à l'aise dessus en général ça dure
pas plus d'un coup de palier mais
certaines
certains pratiquants sportifs notamment
sur la gym sont plus à l'aise sur sur ce
genre d'embarcation quand on a de la
force on essaie de l'utiliser ça finit à
l'eau tout de suite et mais voilà c'est
une première approche
finalement dans l'après-midi pas
d'activités kayak sur ce plan d'eau du
yogolf de Feucherolles en raison de la
présence au fond de ce plan d'eau d'une
bâche qui risquerait de se percer en cas
de chute à l'eau mais l'après-midi à
Feucherolles a été égayé par d'autres
activités il y avait notamment de
l'escalade de vitesse avec le champion
Guillaume Moreau alors là j'ai vu qu'il
y avait un mur derrière moi qui doit
faire à peu près 8 mètres moi je
m'entraîne sur un mur de 15 m c'est un
mur homologué avec une homologuée mais
là ça va être l'occasion de montrer ce
que je vois sur un autre mur donc de
l'escalade de vitesse c'est bien ça
ouais escalade de vitesse qui sera donc
à Paris 2024 pour les JO et qui était
qui est rentré à Tokyo pour la première
fois dans le programme des JO allez
allez allez
enfin pas en avant
allez allez c'est parti
et l'après-midi du Trophée Sport Passion
vous l'avez vu à recommencer avec un
haka qui a été mené par ces deux hommes
par Joël abatti et Antoine Kombouaré
Joël d'abord bonjour monsieur
racontez-nous déjà le haka c'est un cas
kanak qui me semble c'est ça
en parler parce que il est né dedans et
on voit que la sagesse qu'il a et la
force qu'il a ça vient de là-bas aussi
c'est le haka donc du Pacifique mais
après nous on l'a on l'a modifié un peu
on a fait ça à notre sauce et donc ça
fait un truc très sympa donc puis
surtout pour que tout le monde puisse
vivre c'est ça
il y a des conditions idéales pour fêter
le 30e anniversaire du Trophée Sport
Passion tout le temps le soleil tout est
parfait pour une belle compétition et
puis on a un parrain admirable très je
lui dis en face parce que j'ai une très
grande fierté pour ce qu'il a fait dans
sa carrière et puisqu'il a fait après il
était là au départ aussi parce que moi
je suis arrivé par la suite mais Antoine
a été là au départ et c'est une idée
magnifique de tous ces sportifs de
partager leurs performances la passion
autour du golf c'est l'idée de partager
l'idée de se retrouver et puis en plus
il y a le golf la partie mais surtout le
plus important c'est après la soirée où
là on se retrouve et puis tous les
sportifs on parle de nos différentes
expériences et tout et puis on apprend
toujours de l'autre et donc on échange
et c'est surtout des moments très sympa
parce que après quand on repart d'ici on
se suit voilà on suit au parcours tout
ça et tout et là donc moi ça fait 30 ans
on était voilà au départ et de me
retrouver ici pour le 30e anniversaire
c'est souvent émouvant pour moi c'est
émouvant pour vous d'être le parrain
justement de la 30e
moi j'ai heureusement qu'elle m'a appris
donc au dernier moment parce que là moi
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien venir et
puis tranquille dans la discrétion mais
alors c'est c'est le 30e anniversaire et
c'est vrai que moi je fais partie des
membres fondateurs donc voilà je me
devais donc d'assumer cette instabilité
mais ce soir je vais demander surtout
donc à beaucoup de gens de venir là et
puis m'accompagner parce que je serai
pas seul quoi on est plusieurs parents
et ça c'est important dans Joël je vais
le on souhaite quoi au Trophée Sport
Passion ah ben que vive la passion et
surtout qu'un vénissent s'amuser
partager c'est ce qu'on a besoin je vous
dis en tout de nous le mot de la fin
Antoine non que surtout les joies les
gens pardon soit heureux quoi passe une
belle journée et puis surtout donc ce
soir qu'on vienne fêter ça autour d'un
verre moi c'est ce que je souhaite
vraiment ah non pas douter donc encore
de belles longues années pour le Trophée
Sport Passion rendez-vous l'année
prochaine pour la 31e édition
et Véronique iturbine nous a rejoint au
plateau bonsoir Véronique ça va ça va
très bien comme d'habitude chèque mardi
vous venez en plateau pour vos insolites
les informations originales qui ont
peut-être échappé à l'attention de notre
téléspectateurs quel est le menu du jour
alors aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
librairie indépendante qui s'appelle le
livre bleu qui remontera Versailles qui
a plein de projets qui fait plein de
choses très dynamiques après on va
parler d'un concours d'influenceurs je
vous ai inscris d'ailleurs je pensais
que c'était vous l'influenceuse des
Yvelines
bref c'est au shopping
et en troisième on va parler des
chauves-souris petit mammifères très
précieux et ce sera tout à l'heure dans
le 7 8 après les actualités culturelles
du département
[Musique]
amateur de blues autour de la table
Véronique Olivier sur j'adorais le blues
va raisonner effectivement ce week-end
il y a de bons invités bon chroniqueurs
ce week-end le week-end prochain est
dans le nord des Yvelines rurales avec
le festival tracteur blues qui se tient
à samedi à Breuil-Bois-Robert et
dimanche à Médan et c'est Chantal
sipeletti qui vient en parler avec nous
en plateau vous êtes donc la prison de
blues sur scène qui chapote cet
événement on le disait aussi tout à
l'heure on commençait à le dire au-delà
d'être un festival de musique c'est
aussi une valorisation plus globale du
territoire territoire rural en
l'occurrence circuit court également
l'environnement qui est mise à l'honneur
sur ce festivals je veux juste rectifier
si vous me le permettez c'est vendredi 2
c'est vendredi et dimanche et samedi
et samedi 3 à mes dents vous avez bien
fait de faire la petite la petite
précision donc vendredi abribois Robert
samedi à mes dents pourquoi pourquoi
justement proposer ce rendez-vous
commençaient en parler tout à l'heure il
y a déjà blue sur scène qui se déroule
aux alentours de novembre dans les
Yvelines pourquoi proposer ce
rendez-vous à la fin du printemps
finalement parce que bon on a blue sur
scène effectivement au mois de novembre
mais vous savez dans les petits villages
des Yvelines quelquefois et bien on ne
se déplace pas jusqu'à Mantes ou jusqu'à
Conflans ou jusqu'à Poissy donc jusqu'à
Paris tout à fait donc l'idée est venue
de d'amener le spectacle vivant au
domicile des gens donc depuis 8 ans
puisque blues sur scène va avoir 25 ans
et le tracteur blues va avoir 8 ans
cette année c'est la huitième édition
nous allons dans des petits villages du
territoire de la GPS et haut qui est
notre notre territoire Grand Paris
et nous allons dans des petits villages
c'est à dire des villages qui ont moins
de 2000 habitants qui n'ont pas de salle
de spectacle et qui donc n'ont pas de
spectacle vivant donc ça veut dire que
chaque année vous changez de village on
change de village chaque année tous les
jours
et le samedi et du côté de mesdans qu'on
soit passionné de blues ou un simple
initié ça s'adresse à tout le monde
c'est un festival qui se veut rural bien
sûr mais aussi très familial
joyeux c'est gratuit en très gratuit
donc tout le monde peut venir nous
arrivons le matin à 8h sur le sur le
lieu du festival avec un tracteur qui
tracte les normes scènes que nous avons
nous arrivons avec des artisans locaux
c'est pas et puis arrive les techniciens
qui sont les techniciens de Blue sur
scène du mois de novembre et tous les
bénévoles il nous installons tout ce
qu'il faut pour passer une très belle
soirée c'est pour ça tracteur c'est
parce que c'est c'est le tracteur qui va
amener la selle ça c'est une agence
solide t'as pas manqué dans les
insolites et nous avons également une
association qui vient de Bréval avec de
très vieux tracteurs ils arrivent de
Bréval à 10 à donc je vous recommande de
venir les voir et vraiment c'est voilà
c'est ça se veut convivial alors six
groupes seront à l'affiche cette année
que faut-il retenir de la programmation
alors nous savons si groupes dont les
toujours les premiers de chaque soir
sont des groupes complètement locaux par
exemple le samedi soir nous aurons les
élèves du CRD de Mantes-la-Jolie le
Conservatoire rayonnement départemental
qui seront là nous avons également à
Breuil Bois Robert qui possède qui tient
une chorale dans son dans sa commune
nous leur avons donc proposé à devenir
chanter puisque nous sommes chez eux
donc voilà et des concerts à l'extérieur
la la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'à priori
la météo sera bonne sans rendez-vous
tout à l'heure ensoleillée
donc c'est quand même très agréable il y
aura de quoi se restaurer voilà c'est
quand même je trouve que dans les
moments un peu difficiles que nous
traversons les bruits de bottes pas très
loin un moment convivial où on peut se
poser je trouve que c'est quand même
très intéressant à notre époque c'est
très important vous le disiez c'est
gratuit et ce qui est une place à
prendre à l'avance on peut venir
directement sur place chacun vient quand
il veut il y aura également des jeux
pour les enfants des trucs pour se
restaurer enfin voilà et de la bonne
musique et de la bonne musique c'est le
principal bien sûr de cet événement donc
tracteur blues qui a lieu je donne cette
fois-ci les bonnes dates ce sera
vendredi 2 juin au Breuil à Breuil boire
Aubert sur la place du village
rendez-vous dès 19h sur cette place du
village et donc samedi dès 18h30 ce sera
rue Ronsard à Médan cette fois-ci et
vous avez tout ça toutes les
informations bien sûr sur le site
internet de Blue sur scène qui ont le
rappelle chapeaute cet événement merci
beaucoup madame supelletti si penetti
d'être revenu en parler en plateau et
donc rendez-vous ce weekend et même dès
vendredi du côté du nord des Yvelines
pour cet événement musical et on parle à
présent de littérature musique
littérature est-ce que vous êtes où vous
lisez souvent oui et puis vous savez que
blues sur scène des cernes tous les ans
le prix de la BD aux couleurs du blues
en collaboration avec une association de
Mantes-la-Jolie qui s'appelle Bull de
menthe tout le temps
ont un lien et on parle dans le 7 8
d'écrire à Versailles c'est un salon qui
revient pour une cinquième édition c'est
à partir de 11h samedi c'est bien samedi
vous confirmez Olivier certain au
quartier des antiquaires passages de la
jaule à Versailles vous êtes parti de
l'équipe d'organisation je disais tout à
l'heure vous êtes le trésorier du salon
écrire à Versailles comment est né
l'idée d'un tel salon de mettre en avant
les auteurs d'un territoire celui de
Versailles Grand Parc ça s'est passé
assez simplement en fait j'avais créé un
petit magazine qui s'appelait instant V
et qui et qui interviewait un tas de
des écrivains locaux et puis il y a une
des écrivaines qui est qui m'a dit mais
on pourrait peut-être se retrouver et
donc
voilà donc on a on a créé une première
année avec avec 15 auteurs et puis et
puis ça s'agrandit
qui s'agrandit c'est ça qui s'agrandit
évidemment avec le covid ça a pas été ça
peut être formidable mais
mais voilà c'est un salon qui se passe
dans un superbe booker puisque c'est
dans le quartier des antiquaires et
voilà et là on parle cULTURE CULTURE
avec avec de superbes objets et puis on
peut et puis on a 36 auteurs
non pas seulement de Versailles mais de
mais de mais de Versailles Grand Parc
jouer en etc etc et les gens se
rencontrent
les mettre en lumière mais aussi de
favoriser les rencontres directement
exactement et c'est pour permettre aussi
que les que les que les jeunes auteurs
se fassent connaître avec avec des gens
qui sont un petit peu plus connus et qui
sont reconnus
nationalement le but c'est faire c'est
rester assez petit donc on a on a 36
auteurs mais en même temps il y a des
gens qui qui viennent seulement d'écrire
leur premier roman et c'est bien de les
de les
mettre en avant voilà je crois que vous
le connaissez bien ce salon Véronique
j'en parlerai d'ailleurs dans un VIP
avec Olivier certain on en parlera
encore plus longuement de faire un petit
teasing autour de cet événement les
auteurs présents du coup vous vous
lisiez c'est des auteurs qui peuvent
avoir un petit peu de bouteille mais
aussi de jeunes auteurs c'est ça vous
essayez de faire matcher tout tout ce
beau monde oui donc il y a
Christine de Mazières Julie Andrieu
devait venir mais elle ne viendra pas
pour des pour des raisons personnelles
armes Brochard François kasby
François Julien enfin il y a des gens
qui sont qui sont vraiment connus sachez
qu'on est qu'on est soutenu aussi par la
Librairie la suite et et par la Ville de
Versailles et c'est vraiment et alors
d'une autre chose qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est qu'on est soutenu aussi par par
les commerçants locaux par les
commerçants du marché de Versailles et
ça j'aime beaucoup je trouve que c'est
vraiment très sympathique de faire en
sorte que que la culture soit liée avec
le commerce et c'est important que ça
soit
que ça que ça marche oui différents
acteurs finalement ce joignent à ce
salon à Versailles le problème de le
programme de la journée on rencontre des
auteurs est-ce qu'il y a des exactement
de belles surprises aussi après avoir on
va peut-être pas tout dévoiler là mais
qu'on va faire de la musique aussi voilà
et puis il y aura il y aura une des
victimes enfin des victuailles il y aura
il y aura de bonnes choses à manger
faire les vers les 19h et donc on le
rappelle salon écrire à Versailles qui
donc euh déroule ce samedi à partir de
11h au quartier des antiquaires et vous
retrouvez bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site Internet qui
s'affichent écrire versailles.fr merci
Olivier certain d'être venu en parler
sur ce plateau merci après une première
édition qui avait rassemblé plus de 1000
personnes le geek-up festival a fait son
retour samedi 27 et dimanche 28 mai au
parc de Diane aux Clayes-sous-Bois entre
cosplay animation et rencontre les fans
de pop culture ont pu se plonger dans
leur univers favori et cette année deux
invités de marque ont ajouté un brin de
magie à la convention le reportage de
Céline Charles
[Musique]
ces visages vous ont peut-être familiers
pour les reconnaître il faut se plonger
20 ans en arrière Louis Cordy et Josh
Erdman ont incarné les deux acolytes de
Drago Malefoy dans Harry Potter les deux
acteurs sont venus rendre visite à leur
fans à l'occasion du Geek Up Festival
aux Clayes-sous-Bois
Harry Potter est de nombreuses
franchises Star Wars le Seigneur des
Anneaux ça représente tellement
important de personnes différentes
donc c'est bien de rencontrer les fans
et de leur rendre l'appareil parce que
vous savez Harry Potter nous a tellement
donné avec lui
c'est bien de venir ici pour des
endroits charmants comme ça et de leur
rendre ce qui nous donne
des personnes normales et que les rêves
peuvent être réalisés parce que ça peut
être un de leurs rêves de faire partie
de quelque chose comme ça et nous sommes
la preuve que cela peut arriver
illustrateur dessinateur ou encore
artisan de l'autre côté du parc les fans
de pop culture on peut également
découvrir de nombreux stands et
animations sur leur univers favoris je
suis sculptriste sur argile polymère
donc je fais essentiellement de la
décoration d'intérieur et je m'inspire
beaucoup de tout ce qui va être univers
fantasy fantastique pour découvrir les
jeux de société et notamment ceux et
figurines qui sont pas très connus
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui permet
beaucoup plus de d'interaction entre
joueurs qui favorise la coopération et
qui fait aussi beaucoup d'immersion par
rapport à des scénarios plus poussés
qu'un jeu de société normal à
l'allemande et même se découvrir Jedi en
s'initiant au sabre laser un combat avec
un sabre laser qui est de cette forme là
donc on a une lame en polycarbonate
ce qu'on appelle un émetteur qui est
dans le promo donc les metteur il est là
on tient en général le sabre avec sa
main dominante au niveau de l'émetteur
et le deuxième main en bas en bas de du
pommeau on a un petit bouton en général
pour l'allumer concours de cosplay
rencontre entre passionnés ou simple
curiosité chacun a pu y trouver son
compte aujourd'hui si la curiosité j'ai
vu la fiche hier en arrivant au niveau
de la gare donc je me suis dit tiens
voilà c'est l'occasion j'avais envie de
vous et c'est plutôt sympa je suis venu
sur Internet vite fait un petit
événement comme ça je me suis dit
pourquoi pas y aller moi par exemple je
suis plus dans les mangasmes ou même
dans les jeux vidéos du style Dragon
Ball etc
[Musique]
qui est plein plein de monde que ce soit
accueillant que ce soit agréable tout le
monde enfin ne juge pas c'est
franchement j'adore et j'aime beaucoup
aussi les concours les concours de
respect j'aime beaucoup passer sur scène
et tout ça voir le public heureux toute
l'équipe en fait on a vu de près ou de
loin des conventions et on a vu ce qu'on
aimait on a vu ce qu'on aimait pas et on
s'est dit on veut faire quelque chose de
de local de familial quelque chose qui
qui soit justement pas à Paris qui soit
accessible aussi à tout le monde une
prochaine édition et d'ores et déjà
prévu pour l'année prochaine sur le
thème du sport un clin d'œil aux Jeux
Olympiques 2024 qui se dérouleront
notamment à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
place aux insolites de Véronique
alors aujourd'hui qu'on était tout à
l'heure à Versailles avec le salon
écrire à Versailles on va y rester parce
que vous allez nous parler pour
commencer d'une librairie indépendante
qui participe à une opération originale
tout à fait plusieurs même enfin une
originale et une plus classique je vais
vous raconter ça alors c'est le livre
bleu qui se trouve une Montreuil à
Versailles voilà une librairie
indépendante donc elle s'est dit même
très dynamique elle organise évidemment
des rencontres littéraires dont celle de
dont je veux vous parler c'est le jeudi
1er juin 18h30 avec l'auteur Timothée de
Fombelle qui est un auteur très connu
très connu aussi des adolescents pour
ces livres to billonnaises Vango etc
donc voilà donc comme ils attendent
beaucoup de monde
la librairie de Viroflay une page de vie
et donc le livre bleu se sont associés
et ça va avoir lieu à Viroflay cette
rencontre à l'auditorium de la
médiathèque pour accueillir la foule
voilà donc jeudi 1er juin 18h
l'opération originale on va dire ça
c'est la plus classique comment dire
entre les deux
ensuite voilà le plus original qui
arrive il se trouve que la librairie du
LIVRE bleu imaginez-vous est une
librairie test parce qu'elle a un client
un jeune homme qui habite le quartier
Christophe de Rouy qui vous interrompt
très rapidement il faudrait vous mettre
un peu plus en face de votre micro parce
que les téléspectateurs ne vous
entendraient pas Véronique et ce serait
bien dommage de ne pas vous entendre
voilà c'est du direct c'est aussi la
magie du direct donc on parlait de cette
opération plus classique autour de cette
librairie là une opération plus
originale que vous étiez mettre notre
connaissance quand à notre connaissance
alors du coup Christophe Flo de Crouy
qui est un jeune développeur dans dans
l'Internet voilà a eu l'idée de mettre
en de créer une application comme vinted
pour les vêtements devintd pour les
livres parce qu'en fait ce qui choquait
c'était que quand vous achetez un
vêtement sur vinted vous avez le prix de
l'envoi et le prix de la Commission du
site qui quelquefois font que c'est
encore plus cher que l'objet lui-même
bref donc lui il fait ça complètement
bénévolement il a envie de tester et
donc il est en partenaire avec le livre
bleu donc sur Internet vous avez sur
leur comme une bibliothèque virtuelle
vous pouvez vendre vos livres ou vous
quand vous mettez le junk code on vous
donne le prix du livre neuf c'est à vous
d'évaluer le prix du livre d'occasion
après et donc le livre bleu sert de
relais vous apportez vos livres qui ont
été achetés par d'autres personnes et
les autres personnes viennent rechercher
le bouquin qu'elles ont acheté
c'est intéressant
c'est l'économie circulaire exactement
donc jamais trop donc bah voilà
Christophe decroé a fait ça il a déjà
100 personnes inscrites enfin qui sont
actifs sur son site et il existe que
depuis trois mois donc c'est pas mal et
il espère un jour proposait cette
application à d'autres librairies de
quartier lui il est très attaché à sa
vie de quartier et on le comprend voilà
donc ce que je voulais vous dire pour le
livre bleu avec vos insolites je disais
tout à l'heure vous êtes l'une des
influenceuses des Yvelines on peut le
dire Véronique
tout ça on recherche justement des
influenceurs nouvelle génération
peut-être quand même donc à au shopping
grand plaisir voilà c'est le premier
casting il recherche des à mettre il
cherche à mettre en avant des des
futures influenceurs parmi les clients
du centre commercial ou parmi les
habitants autour du centre commercial
c'est du 30 mai au 7 jours donc cette
semaine vous pouvez donc vous inscrire
pour
voilà et d'ailleurs donc demain il reste
une manifestation qui donc dans ce cadre
de la Fête de la Nature et qui est
consacré à des au seul mammifères
volants qui sont extrêmement précieux
c'est à dire les choses souris qui n'ont
pas toujours une très bonne très bonne
image mais qui sont en fait des petites
mammifères adorables et surtout très
très précieux parce que ce sont des
insectivores écologiques en fait une
chauve-souris combien elle peut avaler
de moustiques en une nuit à votre avis
allez dites-moi chef des tonnes non pas
des tonnes
c'est déjà très bien alors du coup c'est
une manifestation
pardon qu'elle lui a joué un Josas donc
demain à 20h45 c'est un spécialiste des
chauves-souris quand un Rui qui qui
anime cette rencontre et c'est une
petite balade à la découverte de ces
bestioles on va on va aller voir et on
va apprendre plein de choses c'est à 20h
18 bientôt la fin du 7 8 mais juste
avant de vous laisser on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo
de demain
[Musique]
et je le disais l'été en avant-première
dans les Yvelines avec une semaine qui
s'annonce ensoleillée ça devrait se
poursuivre ce weekend Chantal sipeletti
en est ravi pour être acteur blues alors
demain matin il y aura du soleil sur
l'ensemble du territoire Yves Linois
température de 15 degrés annoncé dans
l'après-midi les conditions n'évoluent
pas et le thermomètre grimpe il va faire
chaud avec 24 degrés à Rambouillet
Versailles et Houdan et même 25 degrés à
Versailles le vent sera également
présent ça peut souffler jusqu'à 40 km/h
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous l'avais
promis un dernier point tennis avant de
vous laisser avec Yves les noix Arthur
indercle au premier tour de ce
Roland-Garros 2023 il est opposé à
Richard Gasquet après avoir remporté le
premier set 6 4 il a perdu le deuxième
6-2 le troisième va incessamment sous
peu commencer et du côté de la Porte
d'Auteuil à Paris merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec moi merci Chantal merci
Olivier merci Véronique pour cette
émission nouvelle édition du 7 8 à
retrouver bien sûr demain ce sera
présenté par Mathilde Franco belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]